hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
the entirety of Seneca is on the
shortness of life is concerned with time
what we do with it what we make of it
whether we're living merely existing and
so it's quite understandable that at
some point he would turn to talking
about what we could call not just the
metaphysics of time but also human
attitudes towards and about and within
time and in chapter 10 he finally brings
up the topic and introduces something
that sounds very very common sensical
but there's a lot to it that we need to
explore there's three times the past the
present and the future and we typically
think of these as you know lying on a
sort of Continuum where the past is say
behind us and we're in the present and
we're moving into the future and we
easily lose sight of the fact that the
present is actually slipping into the
past it's becoming past a lot of the
past was all these
presence that have now slipped into
there and they even had each of them
their own future and this has been going
on age after age after age now
Seneca is going to say life is divided
into it's translated here as three parts
but a more literal translation would be
three times Tria tempura so three
distinct times that are all connected
with each other what are these times so
it's interesting too because in the
translations typically they'll just say
past and present and future what Seneca
is actually saying in the Latin is that
which was makes sense that we would call
that the past right quote food
the present quote asked what what is
what what's here right now where we are
in what we call the present and then the
future uh quote futuram asked and you
notice that that word that we get future
from is actually coming from the Latin
here and this is all from the words to
be right what was what what is in the
past what happened what is what what is
now in the present and what is going to
be coming in the future hopefully
perhaps the future of course is not
fixed in stone the way say that the past
is and so he's going to go on and tell
us
um of these the presence is brief now
what he calls the present here is
literally what we do quote agimus and
you could say that is
how we pass time right but agimus also
has this more
energetic uh sense or quality to it what
it is that we commit to what it is that
we do with this little space that we
have as we're going to see the present
is indeed brief breva in Latin and then
what else well uh the uh future is
uncertain or doubtful the future is what
we will do quote
what it is that we probably likely hope
to do right and then we have the past
what we did what we committed to what we
spent our time on that is certain that
is not going to change that is
how it already is and so he says this
lasts the past is the category over
which Fortune Randomness in the world no
longer has any control and cannot be
brought back under anyone else's power
and then he's going to tell us something
else preoccupied people the okupati
right the people who are busying
themselves in the present
they lose this past they don't have
Leisure to look back at the past and
even if they did have it there's no
pleasure in we're calling it we're going
to come back to that in just a bit but
first we should think about this so the
present the present is
an instant a moment it's here and then
it's gone it's now in the past right and
the future becomes our presence so he
goes on and he says that uh the present
time is very briefed indeed so very
brief that to some people it seems to be
non-existent there is no real present
it's always in motion he says slipping
by and hurrying on it ceases to be
before it arrives and it no more suffers
delay than do the firmament that's the
sky or the heavenly bodies whose ever
tireless movement never lets them remain
in the same position
so you know this is quite an important
thing to say and he's going to conclude
that by bringing up once again the
preoccupied people those who are too
busy and the present those are who who
are thinking about the future and here
he says the preoccupied are concerned
with the present alone right
um
now is that completely true no because
he will talk about them being concerned
with the future as well but he says
they're concerned with the present alone
and it's so fleeting it can't be grasped
even that little amount is stolen away
from them because they're pulled in many
different directions they are being
drawn into all the things that occupy
their minds that keep them busy busier
than they ought to be so coming back to
this discussion of the preoccupied
he says preoccupied people lose the past
it's not that they don't have a past but
we're talking about the orientation of
the human being to their past he says
that they don't have the time to look at
it and if they have there's no pleasure
in recalling something regrettable
something bad they're unwilling to turn
their minds back to times badly spent
they dare not revisit the past because
their vices become obvious in retrospect
even those that insinuated themselves by
alertment of momentary pleasure no one
gladly casts his thoughts back to the
past except for the person whose every
action has been subjected to his
self-assessment
which is infallible a person who's been
ambitious arrogant unrestrained
treacherous greedy lavish a person like
this as he says has to be afraid of his
own memory and isn't this true people
sometimes will look back at a past but
it's a confabulated past in which
they're the victim or they're the hero
not just the schmuck who screwed things
up in ways that they they could have
avoided if they were actually you know
paying attention following the the ways
that they ought to live and so he goes
on and he says you know it's too bad
because this is the part of our
existence that is consecrated and set
apart elevated above all human
vicissitudes removed Beyond Fortune sway
carried by no poverty no fear no attacks
of disease this part the past can be
neither disrupted nor stolen stolen away
our possession of it is Everlasting and
untroubled he says days are present only
one at a time and these only minute by
minute the present
very hard to hold on to right and you
know you often hear people saying just
live in the present only pay attention
to the present don't worry about the
past
Seneca is saying that's foolish
the past is your possession you can
obviously you can't be in the past but
you can direct your memory to the past
days are present only one at a time but
all the days of time passed will attend
you at your bidding
and allow you to examine them and hold
on to them at your will but this is
something that preoccupied people Rob
themselves of the time in the present to
do in relation to the Past he says it
takes a tranquil and untroubled mind to
roam freely over all these times of life
but preoccupied Minds cannot turn around
and look backward their life disappears
into an abyss just as it does no good to
pour any amount of liquid into a vessel
if there's nothing at the bottom it
makes no difference how much time we're
given if there's nowhere for it to
settle and a little bit later on he is
going to reference something really
quite interesting he's going to talk
about this is shortly after he talks
about how we can recover our past which
we'll get to in a moment he says
for those who forget the past
and forget the past here
Criterium
right so to be oblivious to to lose
sight of what went before right what
happened in the past those who forget
the past or disregard the present uh
neglegons right neglecting the pricentia
the things that are here in front of us
and who fear the future
is to fear to have uh anxiety about
those who do this
he says their life is very brief and
very troubled when they reach the end of
it they realize too late that they've
been busied so long in doing nothing and
accomplishing nothing and holding on to
nothing and he says and the fact that
they sometimes pray for death need
hardly be taken as evidence that their
life is long they're affected by fickle
feelings that rush them into the very
things they fear there's no reason to
find evidence they live long in the fact
that the day often seems long to them
sometimes they're bored sometimes
they're anticipating what's going to
happen and they're preoccupied with that
and they can't actually you know they
can't enjoy the past but they can't even
enjoy the present that they're in they
need to get through it right away and
then when they get through it
now they've lost it they can't get it
back so this is you know some very
important ideas what is Seneca saying we
ought to do how can we remedy this
through wisdom
through you know relying on
the wisdom of others which we can
connect with and developing wisdom
ourself he says that the sages the wise
person's life is ample and scope he's
not constricted by the same limit that
confines others he's released from the
limitations of the human race some time
has passed he holds it in recollection
he can access the past time is upon it
he uses it he makes use of it time to
come this he anticipates he looks
forward to and then Seneca says and
here's a very interesting idea the
combining of these the integrating of
past present and future together
is what makes life long
now
we can do this not only by living a long
productive you know well Integrated Life
In Our Lifetime we can actually expand
beyond our own lifetime as Seneca says
we can benefit from the wisdom of others
he says those who give their time to
philosophy or to wisdom are at leisure
alone they truly live it's not only
their own lifetime they watch over
carefully they enact every age to their
own all the years that have that are
gone before added to their own and he
gives you know all sorts of examples of
interesting philosophers and what they
have to offer to us as
High priests as friends as companions as
guides as all of these different things
that we could be connected to and he
says since nature allows a shared
possession of any age why not turn from
this short and fleeting passage of time
and give ourselves over to the Past not
just our own past
but the past of others why not take it
on
and uh enjoy this measureless eternal
shared with our Bettors and so this is a
way in which we can actually enjoy More
Time by imitating the wise person who
integrates these three times together
and thereby has a truly long life not
like the preoccupied who are really
neither in the past nor in their present
nor even in their future and who live a
life that passes away all too quickly we
have a choice before us about how we
understand
and approach
time